[Music]
come back and he's been in great form i
think on the event he's almost a plus
50 if i remember correctly to come in
for men's list again at the skyline
go what you have to commit so much and
if it goes wrong well you're basically
done and dusted
how how can you say it this man is a god
he's going to find another on the pixel
and another on the top
a third yet as ruxin swings in and it's
all
shaco all the time to win shackles got
himself straight into that huge headshot
onto pengu shutting down the clash
that could be the difference mick it's
just
dumb how good he's been when you've
actually looked at the way that he's
played and he's been doing this against
good teams
in rainbow six siege no man is deadlier
than shaiko
this guy is considered one of the best
players in the world
and for good reason his fragging and aim
are insane
only having to win two protecting rounds
that's gonna be a
bds climbed the competitive siege
mountain starting from the very
bottom but for shaiko this was a revenge
tour
a giant middle finger to all the people
who said he wasn't good enough
to the people who spent two years
discrediting his skills
because for those two years shaiko was
banned
from competitive siege shaiko has been
banned from any esl competitive play for
two years the any money any winnings
that
t b genius has accumulated throughout
this season
has been forfeited as well as their spot
in this season of the pro league
pangu then considered the best player in
the world accused shaiko of cheating in
a pro match against g2 esports
it's still unclear to this day whether
shaikho actually cheated or not
but if you want to know more about that
please go watch our older video
for now revenge a few days after his ban
was lifted
shaiko joined bds esports who were
re-entering siege with their old roster
so they were basically starting from
scratch first they had to qualify for
the eu pro league which meant that
cheiko and bds
began their grind through challenger the
region's secondary league
[Applause]
is
but right after they qualified for
challenger shaiko got his first taste of
competitive siege
in years ago finding a much needed kill
taking the nades out and he's going to
find another on the pixel and another on
the top
a third yet as ruxin swings in and it's
all
shaco all the time is raw fall will put
down the defuser
and shaiko goes hunting is that's gonna
be 48
on the match two kills away from
50 kills inside of one game you take
your eyes off this guy for a second it
doesn't matter if you're looking at him
or what he will absolutely rip you
down shaiko hulked out in the group
stage
setting a new record for most kills in a
single match and
beating g2 the tournament favorites
while bds lost in the playoffs
scheiko's message to the siege community
was clear
he was back shiko's come back and he's
been in great form i think on the event
he's almost a plus
50 if i remember correctly which is just
so mind-bogglingly and i'm gonna use the
word
dumb it's just dumb how good he's been
bds went on to secure a spot in pro
league season 11
which meant there was only one thing
left for them to do in 2019
qualify for the sixth invitational
meepee will need to ace in order for
this round to continue on if mibi does
not ace imagine the pressure
and he's not gonna get it bds esport
punching their ticket to the six
invitational we have
a twelfth team
it's done it's over 7-3 victory for
bds bds finished in fourth ahead of any
other european team
including pengu and g2 but what was more
important is that shaiko
stood out as the most dominant player at
the tournament
with the highest rating of any player to
make it past the group stage
shinko's already worked his way back in
but rafal actually to
stave off text scheikel with one more
and he gets a diffuser
and in the meantime shaiko still holding
the skylight angle magnet will finally
strike four fanatic though picking up
the first but shy goes there to strike
right back
knocking out tex and still waiting for
that peak to come in for mentalist again
at the skyline
what swept with a double that might have
been a collateral taking out magnet
and lusty and now looking for the last
one he gets it as well
it's an ace from shaiko with an
incredibly bold hole
in the middle bar there he goes finally
finished off deep
by printer rx wd playing on the bomb and
he's gone
psycho now in a 1v3 he gets one watching
his flank
wary of the potential there's another
it's all on psycho
in the 1v1 with psycho it's going to be
close the pre fires out and psycho wins
it
what a reaction in just nine months
shaika went from being banned to being
named the best player of the year
and he didn't even play the full year
that's just how
crazy he was other top names in the
scene like pangu
had to admit the dude was a monster
but despite all the praise and accolades
shaiko still didn't have any big
wins sure he was the best player of the
year but
he didn't win pro league he didn't win a
major he didn't win the invitational
he was a king without a crown and as
2020 progressed
it seemed like more of the same for
shiko and bds
they failed to win season 11's pro
league and they came second to rogue in
the new european league
he'll run to get the diffuser he's quick
peeking as quick as he can
10 seconds left can he hit one shot yes
he will
but the double peak will come out and
it's all on the back of leon there
beautiful triple kill that round will
leave
the game in the hands of rogue and
that's for that's bds's first loss this
entire stage milosh
i can't believe i just can't believe it
so when it was time for europe six major
in august
bds were not favorites in fact in their
very first match of the tournament they
lost to g2
getting knocked down to the losers
bracket they fell to the back of pretty
much
everybody's minds but you can
never count out shaiko it's going to be
removed and suddenly only two players
remaining here for bds
but i'm worried about shayko always got
to worry about shaika and what he can do
leon have a bit of free agency on the
top floor but now that they know he's
sat watching this defuser
this is their chance to go a bit more
aggressive they have got time here not
even bothering me
someone stop him and leon man dude
you've had a great day but shaiko in
this series is on
fire the sight in ranchero gets dropped
but there's the pickup from shaikh
there's the second through the wall
drops him down won't have the
confirmation
but look at the bodies of virtus pro
trying to float their way back in
another one
before even halfway had gone they had
just two left and now they're running on
such little info and that's exactly why
things like that
a mission getting gunned down with the
diffuser dropped are able to happen
shockwave does clap back but it isn't
gonna be enough you still have these
players shaiko's so well positioned to
be able to just clean up these kills
shaiko and bds overcame the odds
mounting a loser's bracket run
all the way to the finals but despite
their incredible run
bds were still the underdogs because the
team waiting for them in the finals
was a team to put them in losers in the
first place the team that
got shaiko banned all those years ago
g2 27 seconds left to go there is work
to be done
for bds here they need to recover its
virtue citizen going big
exactly when g2 need them can they close
this out it is now three versus one g2
take it
they are going to go two maps into the
lead
with managing to claw back a hard fought
fixture on villa
unbelievable that it takes 15 rounds on
villa to determine who takes the lead or
would have been a draw of course if bds
had swung back into it
but g two and zero is where they sit
one more map and they are the major
champions bds lost the first game
putting them just one map away from
elimination
it looks like shaiko and bds were about
to lose another
major tournament but then
they fought back aware of his friends
and shackles got himself straight into
that huge headshot onto pengu shutting
down the clash
that could be the difference maker to
the clash but it won't be enough i don't
think
as the time ticks away did bds come out
with a big win there on oregon
they after a lot of sparring were rocked
by a haymaker on villa but come back
with a huge uppercut
of their own on oregon getting
themselves right back
into this fight but they are limited in
terms of
mankind tuna will be taken down by
shackle and he's starting to push
himself forward that's the talisman for
bds out comes the nerd causes down pengu
this is surely going to be bds clawing
themselves back
into the match up here and we have got
exactly what we
and everybody else wanted dez we are
going to club house map five bds have
fought themselves all the way back
from a two-map deficit this could be one
of the all-time classic comebacks that
we are witnessing time we generally see
it come down
to last 10 second bloodbats but the ping
comes out it's all the information that
renshiro needs to shut down pengu on his
belly he gets a third on to virtue
shackle will get the first kill onto
virtue is this the beginning
of the end for g2 that is the question
outcome another
couple of kills one versus five now the
hopes of g2
rested with the last man but no it will
be ally
bds as they take a flawless round
and they are your eu major champions
here
in stage one what a performance from the
french team
we have just seen all the way back from
two maps to nil
they take this one 3-2
after being banned for two years after
coming painfully close
time and time again shaiko finally
had his first trophy and he got it with
one of the most incredible runs in siege
history when the losers bracket team
comes in and wins it
it's so much like it's in it's an
incredible story like it's a good
storyline
that is like right that was one of the
most entertaining like it was an
online mini major finals and like
it was still one of the most
entertaining matches i've watched in
siege
and for further icing on the cake he won
by beating the man who got him
banned in the first place i mean can you
imagine
shaiko winning his first title
against pingu in the finals like you
can't make that up
like that that's such a great storyline
shaiko's path to glory was
long and painful he was banned for a
crime he swears he didn't commit
and when he was finally unbanned he was
forced to start from the very bottom
but shaiko never quit he never stopped
grinding
and he never stopped trying to answer
the question that the community
always asked yes he
is just that good
let's talk about pumpkin spice craft
dinner i can talk about the incredible
channel we have in slack called zee
fun delicious food which exclusively
goes for disgusting pieces of food items
like the red lobster exclusive dugorita
a mountain dew margarita the taco bell
cheesy chalupa jalapeno noir wine or
perhaps pumpkin spice craft dinner a
limited 1000
products only thing that they are giving
to people in canada for reasons i can't
explain who wants to eat pumpkin spice
who wants to eat craft dinner one
question one who want and then of those
people
which of them want pumpkin spice craft
dinner it doesn't make any sense